are you excited for the Xbox ones next
big feature update well you won't have
to wait as many of the improvements and
features we've been hearing about over
the past few months arrived to
Microsoft's console today I'm Matt and
this GameSpot news update is all about
the Xbox one many of today's changes
revolve around the improvement of the
dashboards overall performance in
addition to providing easier access to
frequently used features the home screen
now features a smaller icon for the game
you're currently playing and provides
options to jump to related areas such as
the game hub you'll also see artwork
from the game in the dashboards
background as long as you don't have
custom art already set on top of that
the guide screen has been changed up and
is now accessible through a single press
of the Xbox button
the guides first tab lets you move to
the home screen or access the my games
and apps section Xbox Store recently
launched apps pins and more you can also
expect background music controls and an
easy way to jump into the game DVR menu
but wait there's more other major
features in today's update include the
integration of the beam live streaming
service and a customizable achievement
tracker you can check out the rest of
the editions on gamespot comm but make
sure to LIKE and subscribe to our
youtube channel if you want to be the
first to know when new updates are on
their way and after all those features
and menus you probably just want to see
some dang video games well in that case
check out our video on the five guns
you'll love from Mass Effect Andromeda
[Music]